فقدت والدتها كل من إخوتها وأخواتها
الثلاثة الذين قتلوا في
زلزال هائل دمر منزلها ،
كانت روبرت قبل ساعات قليلة من
هرولها إلى بر الأمان بعد أن تم انتشالها من تحت الأنقاض
ملابسها الملطخة
بالدماء التي
سيهتم بها الطفل الصغير.
عمها بينما كان والدها يتعافى في
المستشفى من جروحه يقول نشطاء إنه
مكان مألوف للغاية مع حسرة
دمرتها ما يقرب من 12 عامًا من الحرب ، ولم يتبق سوى
القليل للتعامل مع
كارثة أخرى تعرضت
شمال غرب سوريا لزلزال بقوة 7.8
درجة وعشرات
الهزات الارتدادية ولكن  في اللحظات الأولى ،
تساءل السكان المصابون بصدمة نفسية عما إذا كانت
الطائرات الحربية قد مزقت مرة أخرى
بسبب الصراع الأهلي ، فإن
الاستجابة لهذه الكارثة تنقسم
على أسس سياسية في
محافظة إدلب التي يسيطر عليها المتمردون.
وتكشف لقطات الطائرات بدون طيار عن نطاق وحجم
مهمتهم القاتمة بينما يتحمل عدد لا يحصى من
العائلات التي تبحث عن أحبائها المفقودين
وزنًا مؤلمًا
ولكن المساعدة لا يمكن أن تصل إلى الجميع في
المناطق النائية ، حيث يقوم الأقارب بالحفر
بأيدٍ جرداء
[موسيقى]
أو
أي ناجين عثروا عليها  أو هرعوا إلى
المستشفيات المكتظة مثل هذا المستشفى حيث كانت
أسرة للمرضى قد نفد منها جثث الموتى
تنزف على الأرض وأكياس الجثث تتراكم باستمرار
في المناطق التي تسيطر عليها الحكومة السكان
معزولون إلى حد كبير عن
المساعدات الدولية التي يتم ضخها إلى
رئيس منطقة الكارثة  يخضع
نظام بشار الأسد لعقوبات شديدة
من قبل الغرب لقصف شعبه
هنا ، إنه مؤيد جاد. رعاة
الصراع روسيا في إيران تقدم
المساعدة لقوات موسكو تدعم
جهود البحث والتعافي وتعهد
الرئيس بوتين بإرسال المزيد من
المساعدة ولكن الكارثة تعرف  لا توجد سياسة هنا
عائلات يائسة للحصول على أخبار أيضًا ،
يشعر الأجانب بأن محنتهم قد نُسيت طويلاً وتم
إهمالها الآن مع
دفع مأساتهم إلى دائرة الضوء مرة أخرى ، الأمر متروك
للعالم لسماع مناشداتهم
على CNN Istanbul